where's the Rock at where he's crowded
where they're crowd surfing together
Mexico he's just in Cancun like sipping
no no no no no no
Mexico not Cancun Mexico oh he's in like
deep Guadalajara said not white Yeah
Yeah Yeah Yeah
Chris said not the safe man yeah not
white Mexico or you have a sweet yeah
the kind of Mexico over there like hold
my baby so it's blessed like that kind
of you know what I'm talking about like
or or they're like cold might be we're
giving them up for a sacrifice
hold it for good luck like that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well that baby's like what in the [ __ ]
it's like Darren aronofsky's mother
yeah yeah totally
how about the rock give me a vast no
shirt
what a great way to find out that you're
the father
coming in the crowd send him his baby
you were here a year ago [ __ ]
this this is your baby that would be a
great moment where he just goes oh my
God throw it back
[Laughter]
I mean what's more dangerous this or
when Michael Jackson hung his baby over
the balcony well that was way more
dangerous
random strangers crowd surfing your
[ __ ] kid to the Rock true but it's
not that high up number one number two
the rock is very capable and Michael
Jackson uh is very frail oh you've never
seen him dance okay all right good point
good I mean but what's somebody doing
okay and he's also holding him by his
neck dude he's off do that like he's
just bad with babies though like like
you know as the baby's going towards the
rock somebody's like got it and then you
just see a dude I know I know that
happened but here's the thing the rock
if I'm The Rock in that situation I go
like this the whole time I'm like no no
no no hey can we give it back to the
lake give it no no no no oh God damn it
all right but I'll do this wow yeah he's
like yeah
sacrifice I'm gonna come down there hold
on stay there I'll come down right right
I'll be right down there you don't need
to happen at one of your shows clearly
it will yeah and a crazy foreign